digamos que son parciales aquí no
solamente es el control del narcotráfico
son diferentes disputas territoriales
que se están presentando por varias
riquezas no solamente el narcotráfico
también está la minería especialmente
mina artesanal minería ilegal es en esto
en zona de el estado de bolívar
contrabando de gasolina también sabemos
pues obviamente que está la ocs y en el
lado colombiano entonces hay disputas
territoriales de grandes riquezas que se
está dando en estos momentos no
solamente está lln también hay dos
facciones de las farc en frente 10 y el
frente 28 y además la segunda
marquetalia todos pues detrás también de
narcotráfico y de estas riquezas que
tiene toda esta zona que obviamente es
una frontera que lleva más de 40 años
con presencia de grupos armados ilegales
con presencia paramilitar de ln de las
farc una frontera porosa en donde entran
y salen los diferentes grupos armados
es que tiene este enfrentamiento y está
disputa territorial
bueno cuéntanos el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro le pido ayuda a
la onu para limpiar la frontera de minas
antipersonales ese es un mensaje en
contra de colombia hoy también cuéntenos
si se sabe de presencia de minas
antipersonales o víctimas de las mismas
en esta zona es una realidad las minas
antipersona están en diferentes zonas
del país y la frontera no es una
excepción es necesario que exista un
diálogo no solamente por parte de
venezuela con naciones unidas sino
también con el gobierno colombiano para
poder limpiar esta zona de minas
antipersonas que son las víctimas
especialmente de la sociedad civil
quienes caen en estas minas y son de
venezuela y de colombia esto es una una
práctica que se ha venido llevando desde
hace ya varios años tanto en
en el estado de bolívar en el estado de
apure pero también en obviamente en
arauca
bueno si bien el flujo migratorio en la
frontera colombo-venezolana es constante
durante los últimos años en estos 15
días los desplazados serían más de 6000
representa esto un nuevo riesgo de
emergencia humanitaria y también
sanitaria por la pandemia y también que
tendría que pasar para que finalizar
estos enfrentamientos es un riesgo el
que se está presentando en estos
momentos sanitario ya como ustedes lo
dicen son más de 6000 personas que han
estado transitando que son desplazados
aproximadamente 3.000 son de venezuela
1700 menores de edad y 200 adultos
mayores es una crisis de alta de alto
grado el que se está viviendo en estos
momentos entonces lo que hay que hacer
es tener diálogo en estos momentos entre
los dos gobiernos para la atención
humanitaria de los diferentes con
nacionales bueno y por último también
preguntarle si estos nuevos desplazados
que vienen principalmente del estado
venezolano de apure podrían acogerse a
las nuevas medidas dictadas por el
presidente colombiano iván duque de
acoger y regularizar a muchos a un gran
porcentaje de los mira
venezolanos o cuál sería la situación
migratoria de estos desplazados se deben
acoger y se debe tratar con con las
normas internacionales de migración que
se que se están dando en estos momentos
rechazar los puestos obviamente no se
puede en ningún momento en ningún medida
y el gobierno colombiano de acogerlos
así como también el gobierno venezolano
acogió a muchos desplazados colombianos
en su momento entonces es necesario
tener una amplitud humanitaria para
todos los venezolanos que están siendo
desplazados pues agradecemos la opinión
de leonardo gonzález coordinador del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz desde bogotá colombia